thank you for joining us America
Christina Alice number one best-selling
author and Ramsay personality is my
co-host today we're answering your
questions about your life and your money
the call is free at triple eight eight
two five five two two five and some say
the information is worth exactly what
you pay for it triple eight eight two
five five two two five Christian starts
off this hour in Seattle hey Christian
how are you
okay I'm doing all right good what's up
so uh my parents I have a little unique
situation so my dad is 92 and my mother
is 62. and my dad has about 3 million
tied up in stocks and then he has sold
calls on those and then he has some cash
that he has done some puts on that he's
kind of all tied up in and so he's aging
I can see that he's
not doing super well and then my mother
is going to be left with kind of this
unique situation to untangle I have
Financial power of attorney for both my
parents and so I'm just thinking ahead
here when my father passes away I need
to
try to help my mother kind of probably
untangle some of this no go ahead and do
it now
um well I I guess I just always kind of
thought it's it's his stuff and
let him let him do it until he's not
around anymore I thought you were doing
it
well he's he has me help him uh just
because he's he does a lot of his stuff
on a brokerage account online and how
does the conversation sound when you say
Hey Dad this is a tangled mess to leave
Mom let's get it untangled yeah unless
you and I work together to untangle is
starting right now Ready set go how's
that sound how's that conversation go
no I want to do this till I die is that
what he's going to say I'm 92.
yeah he's just kind of stubborn but yeah
I should I should probably have that
conversation what's the hesitancy it
does seem like you're a little bit like
yeah reluctant have there been bad
conversations in the past or is there a
history there well he's very
um you know he's he's done well in some
areas and so he's just very stubborn and
adamant and
you know he kind of knows best and so
you know he's even tried to kind of
influence me on some of the decisions I
make financially and
and so
I just I just didn't see that video what
is it then they just be untangled for
your mom give me an example
well so I'm just thinking if he passes
my mom's gonna have no idea what to do
with docs or have calls on them years
out and just
you know
um yeah so Dad yeah Mom you're gonna die
and mom's gonna be left with this and
she's gonna have no idea what to do with
this
let's set this up for her not for you
dad
yeah
I mean this is an act of Love of him
towards his wife
to not leave her in a lurch
yeah
and I wonder if you can kind of make it
that empowering conversation where it's
like I'm not trying to get in your
business I'm not trying to run the show
but I'm just trying to help Mom and this
is the opportunity for you to make it
less complicated for us like just even
make him feel part of the process like
you still have ownership of this this is
still you running your finances you're
just getting us prepared for what's next
yeah we're trying to set we're trying to
set her up to win not him
right right
it's yeah you know if he won't do that
then the best you can do is just make a
bunch of lists of stuff and try to have
an inventory and then go ahead and
develop a strategy for you know
liquidating the crap out of this stuff
as soon as he's gone sorry but that's
just I mean wow how cold is that but
that's what you're gonna have to do just
go sell order sell order sell order sell
order sell order close that brokerage
account put it in cash move it to basic
mutual funds with a good smart rest or
Pro and let Mom just live off the income
that that creates and it's boring as
crud and because your dad's a player
mm-hmm right and that's the problem
yeah
but yeah I'm just going to look at the
liquid I'm gonna turn it all into money
I'm gonna liquidate the crud out of it
that's what you're talking about aren't
you
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
so we either do it now or when he's gone
is he sick
um not that I'm aware of but until he's
kind of slowing down yeah okay
um is is so on in terms of mutual funds
I know there's targeted ones in my
mother's approaching retirement age can
I stick it in something like a targeted
I wouldn't I would not go with targeted
I would just say I'm gonna pick some
mutual funds she's 65 years old she
lives to 90. she's got 30 years to
outpace gas prices outpace bread prices
out pace energy cost whatever it is and
so you just put that in a series of good
growth stock mutual funds they don't
have to be targeted to her age
um I I'm 62. I haven't moved any of mine
to anything targeted I'm planning to
live up I'm going to be as old and
ornery as your dad we're counting on it
too Dave yeah you can't you counting on
it a lot but yeah
but yeah I mean that's that's the thing
so bless his heart that's I love the guy
because he's a he's a player 92 he's
still swinging man still hustling get
after him go run a half marathon while
you're doing it dude but uh oh my gosh
yeah um but you know one of the things
about money and business and assets is
you need to one of the things we're
trying to do is change our family tree
not not mess it up
and not leave it uh to people who can't
manage it not leave it to
um in improper forms which is what this
is the form of investment is a problem
and
but it requires turning loose and you
know when you face this stuff it's kind
of like doing a will
um
when I face this and I start turning
over sections of this company to to the
rent next generation and that kind of
stuff you're admitting that you're going
to die and it's it's disturbing yeah it
disturbs you if you're 92 or 62 or 12 I
mean when you admit you're going to die
it's a hard thing although we
intellectually know it you emotionally
go oh crap I'm gonna die you know I mean
it's like so yeah you got to do a will
you have to set up your asset base to to
be a blessing to the Next Generation not
a curse you uh need to do your
succession plan if you own a company or
you're running an organization your job
is part of your job is to have a way to
turn it over long before you grab your
chest and fall back to the grave and
throw the keys out on the way down and
so no you need a plan and that's called
loving the people in your life well
that's good and he mentioned they they
that he currently has power of attorney
for both parents is it smart for
somebody in his situation to just start
making moves no I wouldn't I wouldn't
relationally I wouldn't legally he could
go just do whatever he wants to do right
now but I got to tell you the guy he's
talking about is going to blow a gasket
I think that's kind of the fear the
hesitation I mean rightly so because the
guys you know he gave it to him in case
he becomes suddenly has a stroke or
something and he doesn't have to instead
of he could have done a special power of
attorney or medical power of attorney or
whatever instead he just gave it to him
now but then did not give him
he gave him the power but he didn't give
him the moral Authority
the the right ethically to just go start
walking through there with muddy boots
well it seems like you must have some
sort of strong personality because the
sun does sound pretty hesitant do you
think he's trying to be respectful well
do you think it'd be good for them to
sit down with like a smart Vester is it
better to have like a third party in the
room to kind of help his dad feel more
it's going to be three conversations
before you get that far man yeah because
this guy's not gonna listen if he wants
a Smart investor he'd already call one
it's true he has a lot of years but he's
doing his own stuff man so yeah it's you
just got to sit down and go navigate dad
is what amounts to and the best way to
do that is the good news about a guy
like that is he probably has a huge
heart yeah and he probably really loves
his wife and that's the string to pull
because that's also the truth you need
to do this for your wife dude you do
this for Mom and that that'll move him
more than anything else I'm moving this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
Christine Ellis Ramsey personality is my
co-host she's also the author of a book
called Confessions of a scholarship
winner where she
documents the fact that she got a half a
million dollars in scholarships five
hundred thousand dollars went to
Vanderbilt and to Belmont getting her uh
undergrad and then her master's degree
all 100 percent free and she's one of
our resident experts on uh you know how
not to get into student loan debt uh
obviously scholarships is one way to
avoid that and so I keep my fingers on
the student loan epic colossal disaster
enough to be uh stirring up a Ruckus
pretty regularly but Christine is our
resident expert on it so
the Supreme Court Matt oh
have they ruled they haven't ruled yet
they haven't ruled yet wait a minute
wait I thought I thought it was all
going to be over February 28th wait a
minute no no no no no no no it didn't
happen they're gonna delay oh it's gonna
take a while oh who knew me
you've been calling it yep and then and
then here we go
our buddies over at Sofi which run the
little sweet little sweet nurturing
commercials about how much they love you
and then they sell you crappy Financial
products they got a nice Stadium though
oh gosh everybody needs a nice Stadium
if you're gonna sell crappy stuff you
should have a nice stadium with all the
profits you make from your crappy stuff
there you go so what's up well now
they're getting into the student loan
fight there's an article that said Sofi
Bank sues to block Biden's student loan
payment pause so this is another lawsuit
y'all and it's not even just to stop the
program it's to stop the pause the
article says a private bank is trying to
force the Biden Administration to end
its pause on federal student loan
payments arguing the moratorium has no
legal basis and has cost the bank known
for its refinancing business millions of
dollars in profits about hundreds of
millions that just makes me want to
throw up a little bit right there like
if you kind of tells you what's going on
now their motivation obviously is so
pure yeah it says in the federal lawsuit
filed Friday in Washington Sofi Bank
asked a federal judge to overturn
President Joe Biden's latest extension
on the payment pause student loan loan
payments were first halted at the start
of the pandemic by President Trump the
pause has been extended eight times over
the last three years the bank says it's
federal student loan refinancing
business has suffered because borrowers
have a little incentive to refinance
while payment while payments and
interest are on hold at a minimum the
lawsuit asks a judge to limit the pause
only to borrowers who are eligible for
the Biden cancellation plan Biden's
latest extension which was announced in
November and could stretch as far as
this summer is unlawful on multiple
grounds the lawsuit claims the plan is
currently being challenged in the
Supreme Court which is expected to rule
by June you know this is interesting the
um the extension uh the polls was
basically under emergency
times in a pandemic and it was emergency
Powers if you will granted to the
president to help things and it has
moved from him
uh Trump first and then later even Biden
uh helping people during the pandemic
uh make it through their student loans
it's moved from that as a motivation to
now I just don't want them to have to
pay their student loans so I'm just
going to kick the can and I'm the guy
that gets can do can do that but there's
no emergency anymore so I think kind of
even though I think sofa is pretty
scummy um it probably stands for
scummify but the um but uh uh I think
there's probably a basis for the lawsuit
I know oh well and it's not like you've
it's not like you can go we have to
extend the student loans
wait a minute
it's over Dude everyone's over nobody's
wearing a mask dude fouchie's gone dude
I mean really you need to catch up this
is so 20 20. I mean really and you know
it's like he doesn't have that power on
that basis anymore well that's what
they're even saying with the whole
cancellation plan right now is he's
trying to cancel it you know based on
what happened in the pandemic and
they're like that's that's over like how
can we cancel it based on that so even
so far in the Supreme Court case there's
a lot of skepticism from the judges
going wait a minute how does this
connect and how can you use this
reasoning if you're also saying the
pandemics over so um the education
department comes out and says it's an
attempt by a multi-million dollar
company to make money while they force
45 million dollar 45 million borrowers
back into payments which is actually
true
it is an attempt by a multi-million
multi-billion dollar company to collect
interest on the loans that they have and
also to get more people to refinance
which I'm like isn't that horrible
marking marketing to be like we're gonna
stop the pause and now you should come
when they were thinking about filing
this lawsuit did they not consult their
PR department yeah I'm like the lawsuit
Swift condemnation from borrower
Advocates who called it a money grab at
the expense of those struggling with
student loan debt
well it could be at the expense of the
taxpayers right now
and I didn't have a student loan debt
when all this started did you no um so
we're paying the interest right now
so
because you know this is it's not hey
yeah I think it's just important to
highlight too that these companies they
don't care about you as many there's
just no everybody in the article is evil
well it's like they're gonna put a
government the Supreme Court the
education department so if there's no
angels in here there's no there's no
angels in a lot of this process this
whole debate on student loan forgiveness
like just like all villains there's no
where's the hero all villains in the
story it's a horrible story The Villain
story but then when you see the Sofi
commercial after all this yeah
and they're there to help you and
they're so friendly we hope you get out
of debt by borrowing on our stuff
remember this get out of that you just
borrowed the debt yeah
you're right you're right no love loss
for the Biden kick in the can no love
lost for the education department no
love lost for so far for dad gum sure
but
good reminder to start paying on these
loans this is all not looking good right
now like we've been waiting for a long
time for decisions and as this is
playing out it's not looking good
at the same time we told you not to buy
crypto we told you to get out of debt
because
it's not going to be forgiven
when all the Smoke Clears
you're gonna have a head
so quit acting like it's not there
denial is not a river in Egypt you need
to actually not be in denial okay you're
gonna have to pay it pay your loan now
as fast as you possibly can you keep
waiting on the calvary to come over the
hill and it looked like Joe Biden in the
lead it's not it's Custer's Last Stand
they're not going to make it okay not
coming they're not coming they're not
coming you are in charge of your life
you have to fix your life sofa is not
going to fix your life they're coming
for your throat the government's not
going to fix your life they're going to
lie to you to get your vote and then do
nothing they do that all the time they
are specialists at appearing to do
something and nothing occurs that is
like a Washington art form okay we are
going to announce a new program today
that's going to have absolutely no
effect but we're going to try to impress
you with it anyway and this is they what
they do full freaking time up there oh
it's just ridiculous it's so sad to
watch it too happen with real lives
these are real people who are freaking
out about their student loans
waiting and I know a lot of people are
going to say well I can't afford to pay
it off yeah six jobs and the payments
are coming like the payments are coming
that's going to happen like you have to
carve out space you can't like you have
to pay those back it's not going away
it's not going away you can't bankrupt
them you're going to pay it they're not
going to forgive them you should have
already done it and what you just watch
the cast of characters here everybody in
the story is a villain you're the only
hero be a hero in your own story roll up
your sleeves get your butt in gear get
these things paid off and quit whining
shut up
six jobs it's what normal people do it's
called calluses on your hands
wussification of America get out there
get it done seriously 16 jobs I don't I
mean what do you my grandmother used to
say there's a great place to go when
you're broke to work don't work just get
your butt in gear this is ridiculous
y'all I mean it's crazy and we're all
sitting around we're gonna quiet quit
we're gonna quite quit we're gonna major
in mediocrity and wait on 15 an hour at
McDonald's to save my life you're not
gonna get rich working at McDonald's
even if you own one you're probably not
going to get rich oh my god get your
butting gear you heard it today y'all
this is your wake-up call pay back the
loans Sofi to the rescue
those are curious words I've heard this
week
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50 percent off everything
site-wide visit blinds.com today to
learn more
[Music]
thank you
Christine Alice Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Ally
and Lauren are with us hey guys how are
you hey good how are you welcome welcome
where do y'all live from Yorktown
Indiana which is near Indianapolis about
40 minutes Northeast perfect okay great
good to have you guys thank you so much
data have you paid off one hundred
thousand fifty Seven dollars I like it
and how long did this take 22 months wow
and your range of income during that
time we started at 185 000 and ended at
225 000. very nice what do you guys do
for a living
um I work in Human Resources slash
employee benefits and I run a skilled
nursing and assisted living facility ah
very good you're doing well
congratulations excellent job what kind
of debt was your 100 000 auto loans uh
student debt and then also a guitar I'm
a worship leader so I bought a guitar
right before we started and of course
you did yeah it was a good Kickstart to
our snowball
so you were kind of normal just bopping
along how long you guys been married
it'll be nine years in August so what
happened 22 months ago that Lit you up
and you decide we're gonna do the Ramsay
way yeah so her sister and our
brother-in-law they were working through
the baby steps and they introduced us to
all of the program and so we're
simultaneously working through it now so
Brandon and Kylie thank you guys for
that so absolutely and now they're
they're still working through them with
us and a pastor of ours had all of the
information he had taught the course and
so we were able to take Financial Peace
University through him as well oh wow
very good okay the power of community
there you go excellent excellent so you
don't sound like you were resistant what
caused you to seek this out after you've
been married all this time doing it the
other way I think I was resistant at
first he talked me into it I was like
sure and then for a second I was like
what did he sign me up for
um because I couldn't you know just go
buy my normal outfit or whatever but
then I found out how much we were
spending on you know normal outfits yeah
and I think it sort of was like oh wow
you know so
um I took a step back and I wiggled in
my seat a little bit but then it became
a game for us yeah okay my favorite and
during Financial Peace universities when
you said that logic catches up to your
emotion and that that explained us
perfectly because I love cars and just
to have nice nice things but when the
logic caught up to it it worked out for
us yeah it shuts you down wow so y'all
did this quick 22 months that's that's
fast and you had a big income jump but
that still is a lot of hustling what did
this journey look like how did you get
out of debt
honestly uh just continued blessings
throughout the way uh we would we would
budget for what we needed to pay off uh
you know using the every dollar app we
use that consistently and uh we would
get weather as an unexpected bonus or
more back on our tax returns than what
we were expecting it was just full of
blessings throughout the whole way God
is good amen so good and just the power
of commitment of making that discipline
and staying focused right it it starts
to roll you get that momentum now whose
brother or sister was this that my
sister your sister and they've been
doing it for how long
they started about a year before us okay
so they weren't that far into it either
right it wasn't like they've been doing
it for 10 years and trying to get you to
do it right but so you kind of when you
started then uh Lauren you're like my
sister's nuts yeah yeah they weren't
going out to eat with us and I'm like
you guys aren't gonna meet us for dinner
you're not yeah you're not fun people
anymore I'm like come on on and then you
know we got into it and we had to tell
people no too and that part sucks but
yeah you became one of the nutty people
yeah yeah one of the weirdos you paid
off a hundred thousand freaking dollars
does that blow your mind when you say
that out loud it does that's amazing
it's amazing and you do kind of look
around and go I worked really hard but I
do feel like God kind of did some of
this for me absolutely yeah which people
I always talk about it's you know like
you're heading the right direction and
uh God says oh finally a smart one and
so you're like as you're walking along
instead of walking along now you're up
on his moving sidewalk while you're
walking so like at the airport when
you're walking on the moving sidewalk
right right you know it's like you're
getting double time here God's pushing
you and you're walking it's perfect yeah
absolutely but it's it's just that he oh
there's a smart one we can help this one
yeah he's waiting because when you're
faithful in the little things you'll be
given more to do I mean that's
scriptural so good job we're excited to
give like no other amen yes amen way to
go so six figures and you're young how
old are y'all I am just recently turned
28 on Monday oh happy birthday wow and
I'm 30. okay all right so before you're
30 you clear it up yeah that's amazing
and we were just talking about student
loans and all the people who you know
don't want to pay it off we live in a
culture right now where people think
like they're gonna drag it around for 30
years we all said no 22 months later
they don't have to worry about Sofi or
Biden
isn't that interesting kicked him out
see you later just like that so what
would you tell the people who think that
it can't be done what would you tell
them to get them get them off the fence
uh so I mean the two things that that I
would say is I know it's kind of cliche
make sure you stick to your budget not
only just make one but stick to it and
then the second would be the math may
not make sense but if you're not tithing
to a home church somewhere you're it
will take much longer even what it
should so you need to be tied in that's
huge uh you will we had blessings just
continuously through along the way
because of that yeah what church are
y'all in in Indy uh Union Chapel all
right just outside of India okay cool
very cool good job y'all very fun very
fun powerful uh thanks to uh the
brother-in-law sister-in-law and to the
pastor for in getting the digging the
FPU off the shelf and helping them out
that's excellent way to go guys way to
go way to go good stuff hey we've got
the uh live and give bundle for you to
say thanks for coming on and doing your
debt free scream that's the baby steps
millionaires book next step in your
journey The Total Money Makeover book
you'll be able to give that to someone
maybe get them inspired to started
Financial Peace University membership
and give that away maybe or maybe go
through the new one whatever you want to
do sounds like you got the old one off
the DVDs or something but yeah but
either way whatever you need to do it's
all for you guys and let let us be a
blessing to you guys as well very very
well done Ali and Laura in Indianapolis
Indiana 100
000 dollars paid off in 22 months making
185 to 225. count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three three two one
we're debt free
love it
well done you guys so proud of you very
well done good stuff hey guys smart
conference is back and better than ever
this year it's going to be a full
weekend a Friday and a Saturday April
14th and 15th and the smart conference
will be really really special it is the
inaugural event our first event at the
new Ramsay Event Center up here on top
of the hill and they're out there
rolling out the sod right now finishing
up the last details on it it is
absolutely stunning uh we want you to be
part of it come out there I'll be
speaking Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney Ken
Coleman George Campbell Christina Alice
to my right Jade washer I'll be speaking
uh we're going to be doing all kinds of
things we'll be doing the show up there
on a Friday live from the uh from the
new event center uh it's a Nashville
event so we'll probably have some of my
buddies that are in the country music
business not probably we will uh stop by
on Friday night and they might like have
of their guitar or something so it might
be kind of like a surprise you never
know who's going to show up when when
Dave's around so I've been known to
cause a Ruckus so come around we'd love
to have your Ramsey Event Center it is
almost sold out by the way uh yesterday
at this time there were 74 tickets left
so if you want to come we would like to
have you but it's just a handful of
tickets left they're 119 dollars still
and I go to ramseysolutions.com events
and you can find out the whole story on
the new uh
smart conference is going to be here at
the new event center and uh it's gonna
be a lot of fun Christina it's going to
be fun and man that event center is
beautiful no I can't wait to actually
use it to actually use it and to have
like a big party I've been paying for it
for two years and I'm ready to use it so
yeah it's I've been writing these checks
to to this the sweet and kind people
that are building it and uh wow well you
did a good job Dave walking up there and
touring really good at writing checks
yeah no they did they did a good job
building it they did and it's fabulous
it's yeah we're looking forward to
actually showing off yeah you know and
having all of our Ramsey personalities
doing different things all day long and
it is a Friday and a Saturday
she'll make plans to come make it a
Nashville weekend for yourself and again
just a handful of tickets left smart
conference April 14th and 15th coming up
in just a few weeks here don't miss it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
all the reporting mechanisms that we
have say our podcast listenership our
YouTube viewership and our radio
listenership are all up thank you
thank you very much audience we
appreciate you that also means there's a
bunch of newbies out there that are
trying to understand all these uh code
words we use around here like baby steps
and debt snowball and all these things
that we sneak up on you with if you're a
new listener and you want to dive deeper
into this whole Ramsay baby steps thing
this movement the Ramsay way
uh go to ramsaysolutions.com click on
the get started button get started
button it's completely free and we'll
help you figure out the best best next
step for your financial Journey based on
exactly where you are today so click get
started at ramsaysolutions.com again
completely free we just want to help you
kind of get I don't know grafted into
the tribe all right Jason is with us in
Atlanta hi Jason welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey uh hey guys I am actually one of the
newbies uh listening to your show I
finished a Total Money Makeover and I
just have a couple of questions about
the baby steps sure uh regarding baby
steps two and three so the first one
should be hopefully pretty easy uh for
you guys uh do I include tithing and
gifts as part of the expenses when
calculating for the emergency fund and
then number two it's kind of a little
bit more complicated it talks about like
rental property should be maybe delayed
and it's not included in baby step two
but then when we pay off the mortgage of
our primary home we should tackle the
rental property then correct
um what if the the primary mortgage is a
lot bigger than the rental property do
we reverse the order or just stick to
the stick to the method okay so when we
say three to six months of expenses for
your emergency fund does that include
giving and tithing
yeah yes sir are you talking about just
tithing 10 while you're paying off debt
no no no he said when you're calculating
your expenses I have three months three
times my monthly expenses or six times
my monthly expenses do my monthly
expenses and that calculation
necessarily create a tithe I mean does a
tithe need to be in that my answer is
Jason it doesn't matter
because that's ten percent it's not
going to move the needle that much
you're going to round up anyway so if
you say oh my expenses are four thousand
dollars four thousand four hundred
dollars let's not move this you know you
know you go twelve thousand go fifteen
thousand dollars for your emergency fund
if you're or you know or Twenty Thousand
if you're you're not going to go right
to the penny like exactly three times
your monthly expenses so ten percent
added to your monthly expenses for this
multiple doesn't move the math that much
it's a great question though I don't
think I've ever had that question here's
the thing if if the emergency that
you're using is a job loss you're not
going to have an income so a tithe would
not be calculated that's increased it's
based on your income it's based on your
net increase of your life okay and so if
the emergency was a job loss if the
emergency was a transmission going out
or you need to buy an airline ticket
because someone across the country was
have passed away and you're going to the
funeral or something like that then
obviously you know you would have that
but if it involves your income stopping
then the tithe would stop so you know if
you really want to get nitzy about it
but really you're just you need to round
up anyway just okay my expenses are
thirty four hundred and sixty two
dollars well four thousand bucks I mean
my gosh times four or times five or
times three or six or whatever right and
try to figure out there what that's
going to be
doing it exactly yeah and you're typing
on your increase so yeah if you're
stopping to use your emergency fund
you're you're not getting an income at
that point it's not tithing on what is
going up in your account so you would
have already typed on that money tithe
when it came into your house and then
it's now in your emergency fund so that
money has been typed on now if you are
you know donating to a non-profit or
church or something that you really want
to keep giving to maybe you do factor
that in like Dave said but technically
if you're getting into the technical
part you've already typed on that money
yeah it's it's not enough to matter so
the second thing is when do I pay off a
uh do I pay off the uh
my home first or the rental first if my
home is a whole lot more when I get to
baby step six uh yeah I mean correct
I'll pay off the rental if it's a small
you know running to people got fifty
thousand dollars out on the rental 500
000 on their house we'll go ahead and
knock the rental out
you know that's okay
if they're close if they're close to
equal we'll put the house in front well
I'm a little bit curious about your
situation you mentioned you're in baby
steps two and three
um they're pretty different baby steps
so you have you have debt what kind of
debt do you have well he's he I've
already got rid of them but the uh um
yeah it's he's in baby step two he's not
right you can't be in three and two at
the same time that's what I'm getting at
and I and potentially it may make sense
and baby step two for him to go ahead
and sell that rental if he's got a lot
of other debt and got some equity in
that rental that may give you the
opportunity to if you can't clear your
baby stuff too that very very quickly
you do need to look at that that's a
good point and you may want to look at
it to clear your home mortgage right if
you've gotten a bunch of equity in it
but again sometimes you have a sixty
thousand dollar house you owe twenty on
and that's the rental and it's not going
to really move the needle much in the
overall situation and then you owe half
million on the house or something that's
that's the situation where we just knock
the rental out well just as a new
listener it's just it is important to to
realize when you're in baby steps one
through three those are different baby
steps when we get to four through six we
often kind of lump them together they're
things that you're doing at the same
time but when you're in baby step two
you are laser focused on pain you're
only into you don't do anything except
two when you're into exactly good point
bill is in New York hi Bill welcome to
the Ramsey Show yes hello thank you for
taking my call I have a recovering
alcoholic son who's 35 years old and
he's he's working hard now he's back on
his feet and he's really uh hell-bent on
uh you know recovering his life and
getting back to what he had what he was
doing before
um and I'm looking at a way to
potentially help him I haven't talked
him about this yet
um it's just something I want to discuss
with you and get your opinion on but
basically he's working real hard and
he's doing is he's doing well but he's
trying to get back to the income level
that he had before he crashed and burned
before the pandemic he was making 130
000 in a company job he lost that job
and he's not trying to recover he loves
helping people and he loves tutoring
he's trying to start an online tutoring
business now and he's starting to get
some traction but it's still early days
so one of the questions I have for you
is I have very high net worth I'm
retired I got more money than I could
ever use I want to give back to the
community so what I was thinking is I is
at some point would it would it be what
do you think of the idea that I actually
start a non-profit Tutoring company and
he he runs it he actually you know he
gets the salary from it he does the
tutoring but essentially I am basically
funding him to do this you know
non-profit tutoring uh it's what he
loves to do it'll give him income and I
get to I get to basically give back to
the community my wealth what do you
think of that
I love where you are with your dad's
heart and and how proud you are of him
turning this around and I'm proud of him
too just from hearing it through your
voice of him he's fighting hard he's
scratching and clawing to get back on
his feet
um
conceptually aside from the recovering
from an addiction part your idea is not
a bad idea and I'd probably look at
doing it
um what I do want to do is I want you to
meet with his counselor and um maybe
even his sponsor if he's doing AAA with
his permission is the only way you can
do that and talk to them about this
because what we don't want to do what
he's doing is he's recovering and you're
watching him do this with great pride
and I am too but what he's doing is he
is he's building life muscles
right and the strain
of rebuilding is building the muscles
and if we take the strain away
it he we might take his muscle build up
away
yes yes if we make this recovery too
easy
right does that make sense I mean is it
the old thing of the caterpillar if you
if you you see a caterpillar and he's
trying to become a butterfly and you
open it up well it was the strain of
busting out of the Cocoon that made the
butterfly's Wings work and if you open
the Cocoon up the butterfly just dies it
can't fly because he didn't have the
strain to grow the muscle with and the
there's a horrible thing as a dad to be
watching him strain and watching him
recover from his bad choices and all
that but those are the very things that
are going to make him the man he's going
to be going forward once he's that man
or if he's the other side of the Apex of
that strain according to his counselor
or his sponsor then I would probably yes
I would do this but if it's just to make
life easy for him that's starts to look
like enabling a little bit
yeah no I was thinking of waiting a year
or two okay how he does oh that well
that makes a lot more sense then yeah
that changes the equation you see that's
my only concern when we work with a lot
of addicts and recovering addicts
because 100 of them have financial
problems so um you know I mean
cocaine doesn't work it's just expensive
and so um you know we work with them all
the time so we get the benefit of seeing
people transform their lives right
before us like that butterfly and and
I'm so I can I can I can feel it in you
man I'm feeling Pride coming off of you
Bill I'm proud for you and I'm proud for
him but yeah once he's healed yes I
would do that this is the Ramsey Show
it's Christina Ellis if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love
create actual amazing relationships
Christine Alice Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones of triple eight eight two
five five two two five Rusty starts this
hour in Houston hi Rusty welcome to the
Ramsay show
thank you for having me Dave sure what's
up
I had a question my uh wife and I are
selling our home and we're moving out of
Houston
to uh out of town
and um
it's a it's not a company assistant move
so we're doing this on our own and this
is for work
and in the current market in this
current environment not really sure what
the feds are going to do with the rates
on the selling end we're wondering as
we're playing now different scenarios if
we get to a point where offering owner
financing on the selling side is a good
idea and just wanted to give your
opinion and you'll take on it
not a good idea
okay stay away from it yeah let's talk
about why all right number one you need
to get a good real estate agent and I
don't think you have yet
have you okay
have you uh we're we're all working with
one oh okay all right and they suggested
this
uh no This was
um again playing out it's called it's a
homepage
it is not we do still have a mortgage
okay
um how much is the balance on the
mortgage
uh three hundred thousand just under
well you don't even have the option you
can't own or Finance it
do you have more money sitting around
somewhere else
uh yes we do have uh saving uh yeah we
do have something to save his account
how much
about 150. okay if you transfer the
title on a home with a mortgage a
current type of mortgage an FHA a VA a
conventional without the mortgage
company's approval
and they will not give approval
then they have what is called a do on
sale Clause if it's a Fannie Mae loan if
it's a conventional loan it's paragraph
17 in your deed and if you transfer the
title they call the entire loan due
instantaneously you have to write them a
check for 350 000 or they will foreclose
on you
so you're not in a position to know yeah
you can't own our finance you're not a
position to own or Finance uh because of
that because you can't get rid of this
mortgage and they can't mortgages are in
our current world are not assumable
and I'm assuming you have a traditional
mortgage of some kind correct
15-year fixed with uh two percent is it
conventional or FHA VA
conventional yeah yeah so you have a
traditional mortgage a conforming
mortgage and so your deed of trust says
that if you transfer the title uh
without them approving the new borrower
to take over that loan which they do not
do
um then they can call the loan in full
and so you have 350 000 due on the day
you sold the house so you don't have a
way to do this mechanically so it's not
really an option but just for the fun of
it let's talk about it let's say the
house was paid for here's why you would
still not owner financially why I
answered so quickly without even all the
information the reason you wouldn't own
or Finance it is the only reason
well number one
who's going to want owner financing
someone who can't qualify for a mortgage
this is now who owes you money
you see that how about an idea that is
to start with okay then on top of that
you're locking in say six percent I'm
gonna make six percent of my money for
the next X number of years 20 years 30
years 10 years whatever this loan is
four and that's all you're going to make
on it while you could have had that
money invested in your current your next
home being paid off and not have a
mortgage you could have had that money
invested in mutual funds making more and
if these people don't pay then you have
to go through a foreclosure procedure
and take the house back and if you're
going to do that and even if they put
down two hundred thousand dollars it's
still no fun you're gonna get the house
back and you're gonna have put 200 000
in your pocket but you're also going to
go through go through a Year's worth of
Hell to get the house back and they may
have torn it up while they did that
and so it's just it's just very very few
good things happen
when you own or Finance you're locking
in a low rate property gets torn up hard
to get back all these things even with a
strong huge down payment and even if
you're collecting
you know eight percent in a six percent
mortgage world you still could have done
better in mutual funds and um
and who's going to pay you eight percent
except someone that can't get a mortgage
otherwise has got some kind of problem
so these are the reasons we don't do
owner financing
um even when I was doing real estate
flips and when I was in the world of
debt all the time I didn't do owner
financing back then because it only
works good for the buyer the sellers
really the only thing the seller gets is
the house sold
but it's really not even sold because if
they don't pay it you got to go get it
back
so I'd rather just take less money and
get out there but you don't even have
that option because of what we discussed
earlier Rusty so interesting call yeah
that's so interesting and I think it is
that point that you made that it's not
really secure money it's not like a
guaranteed eight percent or six percent
because that's probably not the most
reliable buyer there are better ways to
build your money I was 20 something
years old doing deals and the guy
um that taught me about this stuff he
was used to carry back a lot of loans he
would he would do he would buy
properties and then hold the note buy
properties hold the note and they need
foreclosures and get it back and do it
again wow so he had this little like
tote to note type thing going with his
house because that's what the total no
people do on the cars right they sell
them for too much money with a big down
payment and too high in interest rate
then they go pick the car up then they
do it again and they do it again they do
it again and so it's it's a
churning scam if you will but his thing
was really accurate he said the only way
only type of loans you make on this if
you're selling a house is a happy happy
loan and happy is you get enough
interest rate that if they pay you're
happy uh Happy is you get enough of a
down payment that if they don't pay
you're happy to take it back then put
that down payment in your pocket and do
it again so do happy happy loans High
interest rates High down payments uh was
his motto in those days but again that's
setting up a a churn situation like a
Tote The Note lot and you just don't get
into that as an individual it's not it's
not it's not going to be happy yeah that
sounds very sketchy and not like
Financial Peace well you're going to
discover you know if they go into
Chapter 13 Bankruptcy that that for 60
months
they pay their payments to you through
the bankruptcy court and you can do
nothing
um 100 percent stay an injunction on any
creditors from doing anything when
you're bankruptcy you're going to
discover a lot about the law you didn't
want to know in those situations so uh I
would just take less for the house and
sell it but in your case Rusty it's not
even an option for the reason that we
described because of the due on sale
Clause that is in all Deeds of trust and
mortgages in America today all of them
have it if they're a standard
conventional Fannie Mae or FHA or VA
old days back when I got my license in
1978 FHA Loans were fully assumable if
you could fog up a mirror matter of fact
you didn't have to fog up a mirror you
could have an LLC that doesn't have
breath
it could it could assume it you know but
um no more that's all gone long time ago
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
Ellis Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
we're so glad you are with us hey if
you've been in the market for a new home
for a while last year's interest rate
hikes might have put the brakes on your
plans well this year the rates have
bounced around some but they're still
higher than they've been in a long time
and that's frustrating here's the deal
if you're financially ready to buy
higher interest rates don't have to keep
you from buying
not when you work with a good real
estate agent that you trust to give you
advice based on your
local market if the rates go down
after you buy refinance
people did that for decades that would
be not a new thing okay but uh so I
can't buy because buy the house
I'm afraid I'm afraid I'll miss out on
low interest rates well you won't just
refinance not a problem if you're ready
to buy don't let interest rates hold you
back you can still find the right home
team up with a Ramsey trusted agent who
will help you navigate your local market
by going to ramsesolutions.com agent
ramseysolutions.com
agent Samson Madison Wisconsin Hi Sam
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave and Christina thank you so much
for taking my call sure what's up uh
well I'll get right to the point here
um I have my mother is 82 years old give
you a little background on her she's
she's a person who likes to have a lot
of control
she's been a good saver uh she has no
tolerance for risk
um she worries too much about taxes and
government
um one thing that she wants to do is she
wants to honor what my dad's wishes were
to try to have an inheritance for the
kids
um but what she has accumulated she
looks at it kind of two two piles uh
there's six of us kids uh one is
disabled so she's set aside
money separately for her
and
um
she's she's done a really good job at
saving but really has invested next to
nothing
how much money she have
uh round number is about four hundred
and fifty thousand dollars okay
okay
um she's got the the only thing that she
really has that's invested is
um an annuity which I think was you know
my dad's retirement which was she living
on
uh Social Security so she doesn't she
doesn't touch this money
um she's been drawing down on that
account because
um literally she's you wouldn't believe
the the cash situation but it's
basically in savings accounts or she
literally has a hundred thousand dollars
in her safety deposit box
okay that wasn't what I asked if she's
live is she living on Social Security
you said no she's drawing down on the
money
she's living a social security yes but
she also is drawing on that money
because in her mind if there's money in
like that annuity it's gonna go to taxes
when she dies and stuff and I said where
does the money go when she draws it
into the safe deposit box putting cash
and she she uh she takes it in cash and
stuffs it away okay so she actually is
meeting her monthly needs with Social
Security and the rest of this is
paranoid gyrations
it is yeah and
um between that my sister still lives
with with her she's been with her what's
the nature of your sister's disability
um she's got both some physical and
cognitive disabilities I'd say you know
she's cognitively about like what a
sixth grader might be so she will not be
taking care of herself okay now so what
what overall is your question how can we
help
concerned that
um
what my her and my dad talked about
before he passed away five years ago was
he wants to be able to leave money to
the kids which I tell her
he or you have already done that because
they beated the house over to us kids
there's not enough dicks
there's not enough
I'm not sure what you mean there's not
enough money to leave the kids
the disabled child is going to need the
450 000 the rest of you aren't going to
get anything
yes and what
um what her will how she's got her will
rolled up is that she has one sixth
going to
um
four of my siblings and then a third
going to me and it's always been the
understanding that that that's not
enough of what I'm getting is gonna go
towards
being able to supplement it's not my
sister's care yeah it's not enough
because your sister's care is going to
take more than that
if if you bring in someone to take care
of your sister your sister's care is
going to be fifty thousand dollars a
year
yes and that that requires a five
hundred thousand dollar an estate at 10
percent
so your brothers and sisters don't need
to get anything it all needs to go to
your sister
and I I would agree with that completely
and I trust and I trust and then you're
going to have to invest it wisely which
your mom has not done
yeah and I don't know that I can
convince her to do that while how can I
help you today then she's still there
[Music]
um
not sure one somebody uh
you know here's the thing here's what I
would do I would sit down with her and
say hey Mom
450 000 at 10 percent makes forty five
thousand that's what it's going to take
to take care of CIS
nobody else needs to get anything but
CIS
you need to rewrite your will today to
leave the money into a trust assist and
I'll take care of the trust and I'll
take care of assist with that money
but none of the rest of us need to get
any money that the child that's disabled
needs the money
mom you got to take care of her first
you don't have enough money to do all of
it Mom it's not there
this is plain speaking to your mom
nobody talks to your mom Blaine she runs
around acting crazy and y'all all hide
your eyes
yeah you're probably right there yeah
mom you're being crazy stop it we need
to take care of this you need to get
this will redone because if you don't
then sis is not going to have enough
money
we have to take care of her mom this is
an emergency you're 82. we need to get
this will done this week I don't need
the money my brothers and sisters don't
need the money you have to take care of
her mom you can't be crazy anymore
you've got to do this this is what it
needs to sound like you've got to be
very piercing and kind not yell at her
but you have to you know dancing around
the way you have with me on the phone is
what you do with her and you've got to
stop that
that's good that's powerful those
conversations are hard but I mean I
think that you told a very good balanced
line I think people have to have the
conversations and I mean maybe you
shouldn't tell your mom she's crazy but
Mom if you don't know
the conversation I thought I said quit
acting crazy but because she is acting
crazy you don't have to be crazy that
crazy I'm crazy I act crazy sometimes
I'm not crazy but the uh but yeah I mean
you're acting crazy stop it it's not
working you know this is putting money
in a safe deposit box come on I mean
seriously watching the dadgum news too
much your conspiracy theory breath oh my
God the world's caving in and Trump's
fault or Biden's fault or whatever the
aliens are coming and oh my God the safe
deposit box not gonna protect you from
any of that and then that getting that
money out of that safe deposit box when
she dies may be a real chore legally
and that gun money's trapped in there
this is a horrible plan and what what
the reason you got to get the reason you
got to raise the pitch up is there's a
disabled a person who's counting on this
money is it's for them that we're
fighting yes that's so good and I I mean
in that situation like the mom is
probably convinced herself that she is
right and I think it's going to take one
of those very straightforward
conversations
or that
well I mean you start nice like we do
here on the air and then you turn up the
heat like we do here on the air I mean
you can start and icing them by the end
of it you're like would you stop it
you're being nuts you know and just you
know you got to just seriously you got
the
the thing is this has been going on for
a long time and so shifting piercing
through this Behavior this fog of
weirdness is going to take a little bit
of effort and he's he can do it he can
do it and uh I'm never suggesting you
being mean to your 82 year old Mama it's
not what I'm saying but we have to do
what she has to do what's right for this
disabled child this is too important and
if you leave this money to the other kid
another kid goes and buys a Cadillac
with it and then disabled sister doesn't
have the money to eat that's morally
wrong
this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
personality is my co-host today here on
the Ramsey Show hey guys if you
if you something to help us out we would
actually appreciate it a lot
there's a couple things you can do
number one if you're uh listening on a
podcast or on YouTube subscribe or
follow
make us part of your daily or weekly
routine when you do that it helps the
algorithm on the internet uh cause
things to pop up in front of people and
I just found out last week this show
last week was the 19th largest podcast
in the world
out of all podcasts and there's like two
million of them by the way so thank you
for that and that's because you guys
keep spreading the word we appreciate
that you also spread the word by sharing
you can share the link on YouTube or
share the link on the podcast or Spotify
or apple or whatever Google whatever it
is you're using right and share that
link with a friend say Hey listen these
crazy people they've got something going
on over there and we would appreciate
that and you can leave a nice review
like a five-star review one Stars we
don't need mama said if you ain't got
nothing nice to say don't say nothing at
all so uh just it's okay you can just
move on to the next thing you want to
gripe about and uh believe it's a five
star we'd love to have that we
appreciate the help those things really
do make a difference and if you want to
take 10 seconds or 15 seconds and go
subscribe you know share it leave a
review we would really really appreciate
it in the lobby of Ramsey solution on
the debt-free stage David and Jessica
are with us hey guys how are you good
and you better than we deserve welcome
where do y'all live
Ulysses Nebraska no Ulysses Nebraska I
would ask what that's near but in
Nebraska nothing's near nothing is it
that's what is it near what's it close
to Lincoln Lincoln how far from Lincoln
four hours 45 minutes yeah oh that's not
bad yeah okay that's close in Nebraska
yeah wow very cool good to have you guys
how much data have you paid uh 188
thousand
Rowdy love it how long did this take
right on right under three years two
years and 11 months good for you guys
and uh your range of income during that
time we started about 95 000 and we are
at 210 now good for you what do you all
do for a living
I haul Fuel and propane okay I'm a
product manager for uh I.T company so I
want you to double your dad gum income
one of you took a job that didn't have
one or what
no he he took a new job and I got three
promotions over the pandemic so it just
stopped moving up pandemic was good to
me okay
I like it so the new job hauling the
propane is a better paying job huh yep
very cool good for you guys well done
what kind of debt is 188 000. a big big
chunk of it student loans so almost half
of it was where's the rest of it credit
cards
oh yuck okay wow you guys were normal
you had a pile a mess yes what woke you
up and what caused you to do this three
years ago
for me it was we couldn't we we couldn't
buy a one HVAC unit we'd have two in our
house and one we had a block off part of
our house so
it was it was a mess
yeah we we had all this debt and we
bought what we thought was going to be
our dream home but it was a fixer-upper
and we had no way to fix it up really
um and so we had I remember at one point
we didn't have a working bathroom our
you know we move in our old house sold
we didn't have a working bathroom we had
one room that was livable and we had no
really way to fund this and do all this
while we had all this other debt so yeah
we were we worked five jobs between the
two of us for two years wow um working
at the bar at one point I think someone
asked us if we owned the bar because we
were both he was cooking and I was
serving and we were just doing that on
the nights after our full no no right
now it owns us but yeah yeah and then I
think one point snow I remember I'll
never forget a moment that the snow was
coming in through a hole in one of the
walls of this is our dream home now it's
beautiful but and I was just looking at
him I'm like we we have to get rid of
this debt so that we can have a a house
for our family and start a family so
that was really that was a big moment
for us so wow that was a mess yes it was
amazing that's good that's gracious what
you're describing I mean in the in the
South where it's warm most of the time
but in Nebraska no the snow's coming in
oh my gosh yeah wow and I think the big
thing was we were in that house and we
found out we were expecting and it
wasn't livable so we were like we don't
have a choice to just kind of half Dave
Ramsey this anymore
um so we kicked it kicked it into gear
and now we have a what turned the corner
what was the Breakthrough the breakout
paying off our credit cards I think was
a big thing seeing we could get those
down yeah that was that was but you look
up you took different jobs I mean it's
part of it yes right yeah you kicked
your income double moving our shovel
helped a lot yeah extra 100 Grand coming
in that'll move the needle yeah yeah so
I'm curious you're you're in the midst
of you know half the house is not is not
warm like if you don't have an HVAC
you're sitting in all of this stress and
financial anxiety how did you find us
like what really jump started you on the
program we listened to the podcast a lot
we had lots of driving your families in
Kansas City and yeah
I'm just kind of a nerd with podcasts
and stuff anyways so we'd listen and
we're like we can we can do this we can
do this and kept taking more jobs and
shifts and stuff like that and listening
so now the house is completely repaired
too yeah we have a beautiful dream home
now you would not expect from what we've
moved into to there's what it is wow yes
oh wow wow they put it up on YouTube
yeah thanks for the hint yeah that's
fine look over at my monitor there it is
yeah the befores are disgusting though
wow that's very cool very cool wow yeah
while that's before and after then yeah
that's traumatic oh man well way to go
guys that's incredible so this was a big
process for y'all that's a lot of debt
lots of work who are your biggest
cheerleaders during all this
I think the biggest thing I mean we had
we had a baby and we actually have two
now so in the last three years we have
two little toddlers but our family and
we've got our his sister and
brother-in-law and they were just really
supportive they thought we were a little
crazy some of them when they saw the
house and what we were trying to do but
so supportive and that was a big help
well you were a little crazy oh my gosh
or dumb
Look At Me Now
give me a nice place and I've worked my
way out of this you guys are animals man
I mean you clawed you did it I'm so
proud of you it's very impressive thank
you it really is I mean you turned this
thing around it was uh it was looking
pretty bleak there for a minute yeah so
at the end of the day when someone says
um
how did you do that you paid off a
hundred and eighty eight thousand
dollars in three years what is the main
thing someone wants to do if they want
to get out of debt I'll I'll start you
add a hundred thousand dollars to your
income that's helpful okay go get six
jobs right and better jobs go to work
yeah go to work work extra we but we use
the every dollar app a lot
um I think breaking it up into
increments helped and having small
celebrations together I really struggled
seeing how much student loan debt we had
and like how we were going to get
through all that seemed never ending and
just having a system support system to
talk to when we're like this is never
gonna end so you know most of the time
when I do something like this or I meet
the people that have done it it's like
when you start this and you're looking
up at this 188 thousand dollar Mountain
yeah it's like oh in the how are we
going to get up there yeah and now that
you're standing up there you're like oh
it's not a thing isn't it funny how our
minds work like that because now that
you've done it you're like it wasn't as
bad as I thought it was going to be yeah
is that right or not so true yes it did
not feel that way at the beginning no it
doesn't I don't want to do it certainly
doesn't feel that way halfway up no and
I don't want to do it again never so
yeah next time somebody says dream house
you're gonna hit them yeah you know it's
like with a base bomb that's it right
there right in the face that's it no no
no don't dream house me no please don't
dream of me yeah that's that's very good
you guys hey we got to live and give
bundle for you the baby steps
millionaires book The Total Money
Makeover book both number one best
sellers enjoy them or give them away the
same with a Financial Peace University
membership we're so proud of y'all what
a great story your power couple man I
love it all right it's David and Jessica
from Nebraska 188
000 paid off wow three years making 95
into the 210. see the difference count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three three two one word debt free yeah
boom
man oh man oh man talk about somebody
changing their life that's powerful
y'all well done this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
Christine Alice Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so Christina first you decided you were
gonna do no spending yep no spend
January now what what are you doing now
so we did no spin January we did Frugal
February so we've had Instagram
Community trying from here doing it with
us and it's been really cool seeing
people learn to spend less but one of
the things that people's been been
struggling with is telling themselves no
and that was kind of the purpose of
doing this right so that we would all
get in the habit of telling ourselves no
but it's been pretty cool on Instagram
having some pretty deep DMS with people
where they're like man I I fell into
temptation again I just didn't tell
myself no how do I get to where I tell
myself no so somebody sent me something
on Instagram that I thought was pretty
cool my husband went and hunted it down
and it's called the just say no button
and it's kind of you know so many people
listen to the show to have you kick
their booties into shape and to tell
them no and I found this little button
no and it's like so it's like a cow
no it's like people have you in their
pockets
do it again so if you're walking around
through life and you're like on baby
step one and you're thinking should I go
out to eat tonight
[Laughter]
should I buy this random kitchen gadget
on Amazon
[Music]
we need to get this remade with my voice
bunch of them
awesome baby step two
oh
should I lend money to my family no
should I use my credit card if I'll pay
it off each month and
[Laughter]
you're like Amazon right or whatever
actually you didn't say no you bought
the no button we found it at Target oh
it's so great we were also thinking like
maybe it could be like one of those like
game show buzzers especially when you're
not in town if a caller calls in and
they're like so I know you normally
don't recommend car loans but in my
situation bam no means no laughs
oh this is so great well our audio guys
really ought to be able to reprogram
that with our voices like Jade and me
and you you know that Rachel crew is
going well now I've been
people say no no it would be so funny no
is a secret weapon it's really we're
gonna do a whole month of this or you're
just going to sell these buttons
probably just sell these but you're not
even selling them we don't even have
them I think we need a Dave button like
this it's kind of a pitch-free day great
we could even like put it in the every
dollar app
or maybe attach it to the Rachel Cruise
wallet no we could just instead of
selling it we could just make an app
there we gotta be free and just let
people get the app button no
that was a complete sentence
you're ready to go
it's the uh it's the ancient word that
no one hears in America
and uh it gives you great power when you
can say this it's you push the root
you're pushing down your tongue towards
the roof of your mouth
you release Air and you say no you're
really good at saying it Dave I think we
could equip the tribe I'm really good at
this I have a I have a spiritual gift of
no the spiritual gift of no and hey you
know what you say no so you can say yes
later and Dave will help you with it
yeah you can say yeah that's exactly the
only reason I did say no ever so just
don't say yes later more generosity more
enjoyment
more blessings uh and they only come if
you say no now and just live like no one
else so that later you can live like no
one else and you need a no button to do
that I'm afraid we just sold 10 million
of them for Tarjay but oh well I wasn't
going to mention with her story
it's a red button somebody had the Easy
Button those like Staples or something
right they have the easy button and this
is the opposite yeah we need to say
hello button this is the hard button but
this one actually works and this hard
button pays off this is how you get
wealthy so you're just going to use this
on your Instagram DMS now
and then I'll just be like no
no or if me and Rachel are on air and
we're having a hard time being as raw as
we need to be no no
that one sounds like a cow that one
there we go we got to get the aggressive
one ready we gotta get the cow out there
then no that one's bad I don't like that
one but the rest of them are fabulous
that's so good everybody should have one
in their pocket if you ever need a good
hard no if you need to all the Spenders
out there that are struggling to keep
their budget in check this is for you
this is for me this is for Rachel this
is for all of us who need to hear a good
this is my last word no
you've had way too much
every parent needs one
what did I tell you it's a complete
sentence no you think I don't have
integrity you asked me 64 times do you
think the answer is going to change no
all of this that's so great so there we
go everybody who's asked that's how you
say no you know in a culture where
really no one knows how to say no
anymore everyone says yes to crazy stuff
we don't ever say hey the emperor has no
clothes that's nuts you people have lost
your minds you nut Burgers no one says
it anymore you know and no one you don't
even look at the mirror at yourself and
go I I think I should deny myself
something so that I can have more later
no no that's not not in a culture that
functions in deeply into immaturity one
definition of maturity is learning to
delay pleasure and you have to hit the
no button oh that's so good and I'm like
anything related to student loan debt I
should just be ready
take them off the table it's always a no
I love it I'm gonna wait on Biden no
you can do preemptive no strikes halfway
through the question no
don't even need to finish this sentence
we just we need to do like a speed
segment where no we'll just bring up
whatever they want to ask just no
oh it's just too fun very well ready for
it oh I can't get my breath
I'm gonna be sore from this
[Laughter]
uh
I mean that's also also it's part of why
why are countries in so much credit card
debt do the marketers they all know that
people struggle to say no and you have
built a business on teaching people to
say no that you can do it yeah you can
delay gratification you can wait yeah
it's
children hate you Dave but we're doing
really well
[Laughter]
my teenage there was a I remember the
first time I came up a thousand years
ago you remember there's this thing
called Myspace
gosh I am old enough to remember that
yeah Myspace yeah it was it's like
around the time Facebook would came out
right that's where my husband and I
started chatting my space a MySpace
group of teenagers popped up that was
the I hate Dave Ramsey teenage group and
they all got on MySpace to whine because
their parents were on Dave Ramsey
budgets oh and it was yeah it was the
same thing they heard you say no that
was it they did well they heard their
parents say that because I trained them
yes and the point though I mean we need
to reiterate this again in the middle of
all this fun is there's a reason to say
no it's not just to say no it's the same
it's so we can say yes later
it really means not now
not yet
it could mean just no I mean you know no
we're not leasing a car but I mean it
could mean we're gonna get a car a
different way later uh in a smart way
and wisdom always moves slower
than stupid stupid is always faster than
wisdom yep and no slows you down it Taps
the brakes on that that's powerful
[Laughter]
I was talking to a group of kids
yesterday and that was the message I was
trying to get across to them is you know
don't take out student loans say no now
and I know that may sound boring but the
reason you're doing it is so that you
can say yes later by 35 you could
possibly be a millionaire that's amazing
that's what we're saying yes yes to by
saying no now we're saying yes to an
amazing future oh it's too good one more
time n o no
[Laughter]
[Music]
too much Christine Alice Ramsey
personality bringing the philosophical
side to the deep conversation this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Christina Ellis if you love the
show and want to dive deeper on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show we help people build wealth
do work that they love to create actual
amazing relationships Christina Ellis
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
thank you for joining us America Tracy
starts this hour in Ocala Florida hi
Tracy how are you
fine sir thank you
good how can we help
um I was wondering if you could advise
me the best thing to do
um we have a 401k that we need to roll
over from my husband's previous job and
we were wondering if you could advise us
the best thing to you know what to roll
it over into and should we honestly
consider getting a financial advisor to
help this grow because we're very
concerned you know for our retirement
sure because I'm 57 my husband's 53.
um we do have a house that's going to be
still in debt you know
um so we were wondering what's the best
thing to do with this rollover check and
you know should we honestly consider
hiring you know a financial advisor or
however that goes okay yes yes and yes
and let's walk you through it the
financial advisor now you need to keep
in mind I like what you said uh you need
an advisor you know what advisors do
they give advice
then you have to decide to take it you
don't do what they say you listen to
their advice if you have a friend to
give you advice about your kid you
listen to your friend and then you
decide on your own if you're going to
take their advice right
yes sir and so what we recommend anytime
you're dealing with anybody in the
financial world you're looking for
someone with the heart of a teacher
not the heart of a Salesman because a
Salesman is going to tell you what to do
because it's good for them the heart of
a teacher is going to teach you and then
you choose what to do because it's good
for you
okay you see the difference and you can
tell the difference in about 20 minutes
meeting with somebody you know what it
smells like in the room
when someone's trying to teach you and
help you versus trying to sell you you
can feel that can't you yes sir okay so
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on a
smartvester Pros or smart investor
because you're a smart investor smart
investor and the drop down of people a
list of people we recommend in your area
that we have vetted they will have the
heart of a teacher and they will give
you advice similar to what we're getting
ready to give you right now Christina
and I okay okay now what we always tell
folks to do and what I have done and
anytime anytime you leave an employer we
always tell you to take your 401k your
retirement with you if it's available
the way you take it with you is you do a
direct
transfer rollover into a new IRA
and we suggest four types of growth
stock mutual funds and put I put a
fourth in each my personal 401K is in
these four types growth growth and
income aggressive growth
and International
now the way the direct transfer rollover
works is when you meet with a smart
investor Pro they'll show you some
mutual funds teach you about them based
on you learning you and your husband
will select the four that you want this
money to go into you'll fill out the
paperwork the paperwork is then sent to
your husband's old place and they will
send the money directly into the IRA
that's very important
because if they send the money to you
they have to withhold twenty percent on
it
and you don't want that
we want the whole hundred percent to go
over into the IRA and there's zero taxes
if you do it the way I'm talking about
but let's say you had a hundred thousand
dollars in there and they sent the money
to you so it's eighty thousand dollars
you are required by law to put a hundred
thousand into a 401k or into an IRA or
you're going to pay taxes on it only you
don't have a hundred thousand because
they kept 20 of it for taxes next year
and it screws up the whole plan you
follow me yes sir so direct transfer
rollover you select the mutual funds and
then move it back yeah and and with all
of that I love Dave that you just taught
through that but like he said sitting
down with a smartvestor is so helpful we
do it you know we had a session recently
where your smart investor was talking
you know my husband and I do it and it's
just having that professional there to
help you so you don't accidentally fall
into a pitfall like that is super
important yeah and what you've got then
is someone in your corner and so like
we've Sharon and I have used the same
person the Smart Vista Pro here in our
area one of The Originals when we put
the program together and we've had him
for 20 plus years and if something
happens to Dave that guy's gonna be one
of the first people she calls
but she knows where everything is she
understands everything because that
guy's been in our Corner teaching her
which is better than me teaching her so
uh we're working together and you know
we're all and we're all informed and we
know who who the players are and you
develop a long-term relationship with
someone that is and then when they call
you and say hey I've got an idea I want
to talk to you about here's some
something you can learn about and here's
what's going on out there you go okay
um I I might act on that or I might not
you know and then you've got this person
to go to after that so you're you're
very wise on all of these fronts Tracy
to do that ramseysolutions.com and click
on Smart investor and uh that'll get you
there it's under the ELP type of a
program the Ramsay trusted Bunch right
and uh so when you mention that you can
often smell you know smell fish in the
water you can smell somebody who's not
directing in the right direction but I
think a lot of people can't that's why
they end up with whole life insurance
that's why they end up with annuities
and things like that so they know that
you're going nowhere they they the
smells in the room and they knew it but
they were so desperate to try to do
something smart and sometimes times an
insurance agent or an investing per
investment person they'll intimidate you
you feel you know like I they they might
I know I kind of have this bad feeling
but they're seems so smart I must be the
one that's wrong and I gotta and I need
to get something going and so I'll go
I'll go ahead and do this and it's this
intimidation Factor this
self-consciousness this insecurity and
you don't listen to your own Spirit
God's spirit in you is saying this one's
not good and you're going yeah I know
but he seems so smart and I feel so dumb
and I gotta get I gotta get some
investing going and and you you push
down what God's spirit is telling you
push down what you know inside of you
this is a person I don't need to be
dealing with and you deal with them
anyway people do that when they're
buying a car and the guy's slimy but
they want the car so bad they Overlook
the Slime yeah and I mean those people
are designed they they practice selling
that they have done this thousands of
times they've rehearsed their scripts
they're ready for it they they are ready
to convince you you that even if your
Spidey senses are going off even if
you're feeling that weird feeling
they've practiced the objections right
they've gone through what are the
typical objections people have and how
do I respond so then again make them
feel a little bit dumb and like I know
more and convince them to get what I
want them to get it's it's really it's
contempt they just kind of roll their
eyes and like oh you just you're silly
you silly people don't understand it's
just it's so it's so nasty there is one
whole life company that actually teaches
a session called intimidation selling
what yeah how to make people feel small
so they buy I mean it really it didn't
and it works it really does work it
doesn't work long term but it's not a
good way to do business obviously but
it's effective and it'll it'll get the
sale done so yeah it's so our goal
around here is not do what Dave said or
do what Ramsay says our goal around here
is understand it so you do what you say
and you learn to trust your own
instincts when you're in a room and you
smell a rat you go oh there's a reason
smells like a rat there's a rat and I
should get away from the rat yes run run
rat bait run this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today a lot of
you got questions about taxes we get it
taxes are confusing they help you better
handle them we'll unpack a question of
two occasionally during tax season here
from our listeners they've around a
daycare and this is my first year I'm
trying to figure out what expenses are
tax deductible well there's a lot of tax
deductions you can take as a small
business owner what they have to do with
a small business home office expenses
liability insurance self-employment
taxes advertising rent anything
associated with the business if you're
running a home daycare you have the
ability to write off a portion of the
home that's being used for the business
to appreciate it
um however you recapture that and have
to pay taxes on it when you sell it when
you sell your home otherwise it's tax
free up to a half million dollars so I
wouldn't fool with depreciation and
recapture on writing off your home
office square footage as a depreciation
but any dollars that you spend you need
to be running a separate checking
account on your little business and all
of your day care income goes into that
and the only thing that goes out of that
is daycare expenses so if you're buying
supplies or food or diapers or whatever
you're buying sheets I don't care what
advertising whatever it is you're buying
they need to come out of that and then
that gives you the list of things that
are deductible you don't buy groceries
for you out of that account if you've
got profit in that account you take it
out of that account as an income and put
it in your personal account and do your
personal home there but keep your home
and your business
uh accounting completely separate even
though the daycare is in your home
physically and then that enables you to
do your right it's really really easy
when tax time comes around if you want
to file your taxes with confidence go to
ramsesolutions.com tax
ramseysolutions.com
tax we have a new sponsor for our
question of the day we announced them
yesterday we're so thrilled to have them
on board neighborly Ramsey Show question
of the day sponsored by neighborly your
hub for Home Services things like Mr
Rooter and Mr Electric are part of
neighborly and you need to check them
all out for repairs and maintenance to
Remodeling and upgrades and neighborly's
trusted home service providers have
trained local experts who can handle
about any job go to neighborly.com and
you can find the different services and
even schedule a service today today's
question comes from Jeremy in California
my wife and I just started reading Total
Money Makeover and are now in baby step
two I understand with the debt snowball
that I should have my debts from lowest
to highest but what do I do when it come
comes to bills and collections how do I
prioritize them do we do them first or
do we just put them in line with our
current debt
two kinds of bills are in collections
ones you're paying on and ones you
aren't hmm the ones you're paying on
they're just part of that snowball just
keep paying them the ones you aren't are
just sitting there
and I would just set those to the side
and then work those as a separate dead
snowball after you clear the things you
are paying on
so if you've got a MasterCard you're
current on but you've got an old bill of
some kind that's in collections and
you're paying 50 a month on that and
just put that in there like it's a
regular payment in your debt snowball
clear all of those meanwhile you've got
something else sitting over here that
hasn't called you in a while or they're
calling you but you're not paying them
right now you just let them sit there
until you clear off all your debts that
you are paying because when you get rid
of all those you don't have any payments
anymore now you got more money to attack
those that are just sitting there and
then you call and settle those one at a
time in writing No Electronic access to
your checking account
interesting so would you put the ones
that you're not
maybe even further back in the debt
snowball or they're just a different
debt snowball totally different that's
done after you don't touch them don't
touch me just list those smallest to
largest when you're completely clear of
your debt that you're paying payments on
now you got a lot of money
because you don't have any payments
anymore then you take the smallest one
you call them up and you go hey you know
last time we looked we owed you a
thousand dollars uh we can give you 450
for that today we'll settle it right now
and You Begin the negotiation and you
settle it you get the settlement amount
in writing you do not give them
electronic access to your checking
account you settle it otherwise you get
the money to them by wire or something
else but do not let them get into your
account because they'll clean you out
but settle each one in writing settle it
in writing settle it in writing and if
the first one doesn't want to settle
they want to Jack around then go to the
next one and go I got 450 you know and
they'll go well okay we can't do that
and I said well I'll call you back when
I got some more but you know if you want
some money today that's how much I got
today and you can work out deals with
the different ones as you go through
those and and it it's a little more
hassle to work through them but you work
through those that way and each time
you're doing that in a lump sum not in
payments don't you're not going to
settle stuff with payments that'll keep
you in tied to a collector forever and
ever amen don't do that it's not someone
you want to be tied to yeah for real
Dion's with us in Dallas hey Dion what's
up
hello Dave and Christina thanks for
taking my call sure how can we help
yeah I have a question concerning my son
he is uh 26 years old uh he's currently
paying fifteen hundred dollars a month
in rent
and he works as a military contractor so
he's only in town six to eight weeks out
of the year
and those six to eight weeks are not
consecutive so he's asking to come home
and stay here
um and I'm just wondering what's the
best Avenue
Avenue for where he stays or or yeah
if I allow him to stay what's the best
Avenue for the eighteen thousand dollars
that that he would be saving
so where where he's going to save that
money where's he going to say what's he
going to do with it yeah currently he's
paying fifteen hundred dollars but if he
doesn't have the rent what's he gonna do
with the money
that's that's my question oh do we yeah
do we um save that money for his first
property his his own property do we
invest that uh 18 000 what's the best
Avenue well what's a little bit more
about his financial picture does he have
any debt
no no he's dead free okay and he has a
fully funded emergency fund
correct and he's and he's he's capable
of paying the 18 000 so I mean he's
doing well no need though it's a waste
because he's never there correct he'd be
cheaper he'd be cheaper to just rent a
hotel when he's in
yeah yeah I I thought about that as well
depends on what kind of life he wants to
have I don't care but um
you know it's not it's not a Wii Dion
he's 26 is what he wants to do with his
money but if he called me and said what
do I do with this extra money uh I I
would do exactly what you said I would
build up a side fund for the purchase of
his first home I would assume start
saving like crazy for his first home he
also needs to be putting out of his
income 15 away for retirement in his
401k if it's available or if not get
with a smart vister Pro and get a Roth
IRA going but um you know uh if he does
come to your house
um I would I as his dad would want two
things I would want an exit date
pre-arranged
this is for one year
maximum after that we're going to figure
out something else but this is to get
you out of that lease and get you
started and two
um I want to know that something Smart's
happening with that 1500 I don't care
what it's your money son but I wanna I
want you to tell me what it is and I
want you to do that smart thing with it
I'm not
um letting you come and live here so you
can drink an extra fifteen hundred
dollars a month that's not the plan
um so that's you know I want to know
something good is happening but it
sounds like this kid's real responsible
yeah it does not only he's responsible
and I think that's a good way of saying
it Dave to say make sure that he's doing
something smart with it but as long as
it's something smart unless he's
listening to the call unless you guys
are diving into this research together
and you're really brainstorming I mean
it's really up to him what he does with
that money and I think there's a little
bit of a risk when you know the kids
moving back into the house and the dad's
calling and asking you know what do we
do with this money it's not a wee it's
not a wee it's it's he's 26 years old
French you're in Texas
wee-wee right there we go you know
there's no we here he's 26 he's a man so
he gets the two huge but yeah but but if
he's going to live in my house we're
going to have a couple we're going to
know when you're leaving
because I love you and you need to leave
and be a man my son and I also need to
know that that if we're doing this for
to save the 1500 I want you I want just
tell me what you're doing with it yep so
that I know and then I'll trust you and
that's that you don't owe any rent but
your rent is you have an exit date and a
plan you start your 401k and what are
you going to do smart with your 1500
might be running some of it into
retirement might be part of it
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions on the debt free stage
Alex and Rachel are with us hey guys how
are you good how are you hi Dave hi
Christina welcome welcome good to have
you guys where do you all live
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania oh great City
Welcome to Nashville good to have you
here and how much debt have you two paid
off
so together we paid off fifty seven
thousand one hundred and eighty dollars
and 77 cents love it how long did this
take well it took us one year together
but then before that I paid off 65
722 by myself before we got married
before you got married yeah okay and so
you've been married a year all right
very cool and your range of income since
you've been married let's start with
that
so it was 45 when it was just me and
then it was 97 when we were together
cool what do you all do for a living I'm
a corporate trainer and I'm a manager
for a rental car company excellent very
cool so what kind of debt was the 57 and
the 65 all kinds what wasn't it Dave
absolutely it's on the sign here okay
yeah so we had both of our student loans
was most of it and then we had his car
my car credit cards and a medical bill
oh wow look at you okay normal you
should be a graphic artist really I mean
this is pretty yeah it's very neat very
cool the signs the shirt everything
y'all are all in this is great this is
totally great yeah live like no one else
t-shirts and here you are I've Got a
Feeling Rachel you started all of this
since you started before the marriage so
tell us the story so I graduated college
and I was making 45
000 and I had 75 000 in student loans
and I didn't know where to start and so
I told my friend Janae hi Janae and she
said my husband and I follow the Dave
Ramsey plan I said I don't know what
that means she's like that snowball I'm
like I don't know what that means I
don't know what that is so she sent me
your YouTube channel and I was watching
those and then I read your book and I
was in so when we met we I was telling
him about it and then when we got
engaged our church actually paid for us
to go through FPU together oh very good
like this church who's the church so we
actually when we first got married we
were living in Virginia so it was love
church in Manassas Virginia oh yeah okay
but what a great thing to do for young
couples when they're engaged that's a
part of the pre-marriage counseling is
go through Financial Peace University it
made a huge difference in our
relationship and with our money
definitely helped a lot of problems
before those problems actually started
in the marriage yeah it's preemptive
strike exactly like the church is true
to its name that's very loving yeah I'm
very loving from Love Church yeah amen
very very cool so what did this journey
look like for y'all you got married was
it you got one year ago yeah so we got
married last November and then we
finished in December so we took a month
to figure out you know our new budget
getting our finances combined and then
January 1st we were hitting the ground
running so were you finished in December
were you resistant at all like she's all
in and this is new to you are you like
let's go or I was for it because she I
mean she's been just the rock for me in
like this whole thing
um I'd never done a budget before so
that was a huge huge thing I wasn't a
huge fan I was like this thing this is
not great I'm not a fan of this but as
months go on we started you know doing
the dead snowball paying off debts left
and right I was like we're gonna do this
like this is awesome and I'm all about
the budget now I'm all about using you
know like every dollar app and all that
stuff it's it was crazy it was just huge
life change wow wow it's amazing what
momentum can do when you start feeling
the winds when you see the winds it's
like all right let's go let's keep going
Rachel how long did it take you to do
the 65 000. three three years okay all
right this is pretty impressive y'all
very very cool and then the combined
income and the combined energy now uh
man I mean you got a hundred thousand
dollar income and no debt this is uh
yeah you set up baby this is good how
old are you two so I'm 27 and I'll be 30
on Sunday oh y'all are gonna be so rich
I love that you can feel it you can feel
it from them like you can feel the
momentum through the glass it's like
these people they're not done like
they're gonna keep going
and you know the interesting thing
that's hard hard to uh quantify at this
point but the very first thing you did
in your brand new marriage was slay a
dragon together and so the next time a
different Dragon not a money Dragon but
something else comes up you know now
automatically you know instinctually you
will know I can trust him I can trust
her we can lock arms and we'll kill this
Dragon whatever it is because other
dragons are gonna come you know they're
going to come we just don't know what
they are as we go through our lives and
so but once you've mastered the art and
the science of working together to slay
a dragon then dragon's got no chance
they got no chance it it it it it it
solidifies your marriage in that way
that's and again that's not tangible you
can't really put a dollar figure on that
but that's a skill life skill that you
all got out of doing this through the
church and the way y'all put this
together so proud of y'all oh thank you
well done who was your uh who was your
biggest cheerleaders it looks like you
brought some with you yeah yes we
brought both sets of our parents all
right well they got to be proud and
thrilled because they know you'll never
live in their basement exactly this is
something yeah
yeah it's your own at your full-time job
now yes I love it way to go you guys
very proud of y'all well done well done
well done good stuff all right now we
back up you said the budget's a big deal
what do you tell people when they go all
right you freaks I mean y'all are weird
you paid off you know 130 000 worth of
debt 57 of it in the first year of
marriage you actually don't fight about
money you actually have a plan like
grown-ups and stuff how did you do that
tell people what the key is
budget
having a vision that you share together
I feel like that's when he really came
on board is when we like big picture saw
the next 5 10 20 years down the road
what we wanted our marriage look like
our family our financial situation and
then kind of backtracking from there
because I said I love that and being
consistent about it and just remembering
we're never going back there yeah amen
that's that's in the past that is in the
rearview future and that's just that
we're done with that life that's so good
okay so I love that you you've got the
vision you already said you've got your
five ten you know what's next you've met
this huge milestone you got over this
debt now now what's the next five years
so last month we finished our baby step
three what yeah all right
flying through that and then we're going
to try to go to Europe this year and
we're saving for a house yes you should
I like it I like it I like it I like it
way to go y'all hey we got the baby
steps bundle for you the uh live and
give bundle it's the baby steps
millionaires book which you are on your
way as I said to be that and The Total
Money Makeover book to give away and
Inspire someone like your lives have
done
and a Financial Peace University
membership which started the whole thing
for you you can give that to a friend a
family member help them get them going
we're going to give give you the ability
to pay it forward with some of these
things thank you guys so much
do you think you are heroes man be here
you are heroes you're amazing it's
powerful to watch you this is uh you're
inspiring lots of people doing this
stuff lots of people are doing this
stuff and they're people just like Alex
and Rachel from Pittsburgh 57 000 paid
off in the first year of marriage and
she knocked out 65 before they started
that making 45 up to 97 now count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one we're dead free yeah
oh my goodness that is how it's done I'm
just like sitting here thinking make
sure you call us for the baby steps
millionaire theme hour here in a few
years I can just feel it happening a
hundred dollars a month invested from 25
to 65 is 1.1 million dollars
so you realize what two thousand dollars
a month invested is because they don't
have any payments
from 25 to 65. that's
20 million dollars
huh if I'm half wrong
I think they're going to be okay they're
gonna be okay they're gonna be real good
what I just said they're gonna be rich
that's the actual math behind me saying
you're going to be rich it wasn't just
like a like this this yeah a dream they
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
they're 25 years I mean
awesome
[Music]
the Ramsey Show
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here
our scripture of the day James 4 14 yet
you do not know what tomorrow will bring
what is your life for you are a Mist
that appears for a little time and then
vanishes
Evangeline Booth said it's not how many
years we live but what we do with them
Noah is in Columbus Noah welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve man what's up
I could have guessed sir so thanks for
taking my call uh I am hoping for some
advice on my house hunt here so I'm not
doing anything too crazy too quickly
um I'm fervently regretting not pulling
the trigger sooner on buying a house
um when things were more affordable from
both price and right perspective
um said everyone who's ever waited at
all
yeah
yeah I mean this this narrative is
getting as overplayed as Don't Stop
Believing by Journey
you know
but but you know there aren't many
listings I I have very specific
parameters on the house that I want I am
uh almost totally blind so I can't drive
and there is this program for
transportation that's my main concern
here is there's this program I have in
my city where it's subsidized it's a
dollar a mile door-to-door car
transportation but I can't really
predict what the government's gonna do
maybe they'll shut it down I don't want
to buy a house way far away from a bus
stop and then they go oh we're gonna you
know take back this program that's why
so I
yeah I want to be in a house that's you
know I I started out saying a half a
mile from a bus stop and
you know now like in let's see I've been
doing this for a month now and I've
gotten exactly two listings in the area
that I wanted and who's looking for you
well I've got hooked up with one of your
local elps
um right and they've only found two so
far that meet the criteria
well I'm
well I mean I have like a area where
where it searches because they're it's
not like a perfect square
so there's parts of it there's listings
that are coming in that don't really
that I just kind of dismiss
um just based on like I have it's kind
of hard for me to explain to him exactly
what I want I know what I want but it's
kind of hard to like customize it in the
MLS you know what I'm saying so yeah but
you ought to be able to tell oh he can't
he can't put it in the MLS but he can be
watching or she can be watching for you
and and filter it out for you that's
what that's why it's only down to two is
that right
I mean I I think I could already start
looking you told me enough already
okay you're side impaired you need to be
near a bus stop uh within a half of a
mile bus stop and then you give me the
perimeters in the street areas
um and then you've probably giving them
a few other guidelines apparently the
type of House are probably one level
maybe I don't know what
yeah I mean like the my price range 350
or less yeah I'm preferably much less
yeah you know a certain square footage
and all of that but I mean what he's
giving me does encompass my entire area
and I can tell you there have only been
two listings so far that have really
really gotten gotten me excited okay so
what's your question in the last month
yes so my question is
I I'm wondering how much of these
parameters or you know quality of the
home things of that nature I should
sacrifice in in
um in favor of you know jumping on an
opportunity well maybe it's not the
perfect house
but
um at least it gets me out of renting
I'm sick of renting well you can decide
as far as the quality the layout the
square footage those kinds of things uh
the only one I would tell you not to
sacrifice on is it needs to meet your
basic living standards which is going to
be the bus stop thing okay and it's
obviously whatever whatever issue you've
got that issues you need to deal with as
far as floor plan and those kinds of
things which I would imagine are
reasonable but uh you need to know you
know navigate that and then don't go oh
I can afford anything because I have
these specific problems no that's going
to put you in more problems no so don't
don't find that don't violate the
financial boundaries that you set for
yourself
list them out and prioritize like even
going down to you said I have a certain
square footage requirement here's my
financial requirement here's the bus
stop requirement all of that and you
know you said that with the agent that
they don't even know your requirements
completely and they're not completely
clear on what you're looking for so I
would do that both for yourself and for
your agent so that they can be on the
lookout and be really actively looking
for you and then for you to go man okay
if a house comes out and it's not and
it's 1500 square feet versus 2 000
square feet the square footage isn't as
important to me I'm willing to go down
on that yeah yeah and you know I'd love
to have three bedrooms but I can deal
with two right I'd love to have X but I
can deal with it why you know and those
kinds of things but the location
um the configuration to deal with the
site impairment and the location near a
bus stop is I I don't think those I
think those are deal breakers you just
yeah we're not going to do that that's
going to be at the top of that list and
then then the thing you got to mix into
the equation Noah and you've already
said it is um I have some very specific
requirements yes you do and that's going
to narrow the market yes it is and that
means it's probably going to take a
little longer and a little more effort
to get it right but when you get it
right you're going to be glad you did
and so uh narrow your requirements
enough that you can reasonably find
something but not so much that you end
up buying something that's not usable in
your situation don't do that and another
important part of that conversation is
just and this is kind of a hard
conversation it's just grieving what the
market was you said that you have a
tough time you're like man I wish I
would have bought but then letting that
go and going okay like this is the
market now and these are the
requirements I can afford and just kind
of figuring out what you can be content
with yeah man
you know those houses down here south of
Us in Spring Hill yes you know how many
of those I could have bought in 2008 uh
for probably a lot for about 15 percent
of what they're selling now
and I didn't
I'm kind of grieving that
Chris is in Dallas Texas hey Chris
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave how are you thank you what's up
well here is my situation I'll give you
kind of a list of facts I just uh
totaled my paid off vehicle okay that
was hit oh no are you okay
I'm okay I walked away and thankfully
um so I currently do not have a vehicle
how much Insurance gonna give you for it
insurance is going to give me eight
thousand dollars which is what the car
is worth right
uh the car was paid off and that's what
it was paid off I said it's What It's
Worth right
yes sir it was a 2012. so you were
driving an 8 000 car now you got eight
thousand dollars coming from the
insurance company okay how can we help
yes sir okay I'm trying to determine how
much cars should I purchase and I say
that because I would like to buy my
first townhouse in the next 18 months
and
um you know the deal was I was actually
going to purchase it before
um before the crash but with prices and
inventory as they are it makes more
sense to wait for better options and
locations so I wanted to see how much
car I should get
um we have money saved for your down
payment on the townhouse
um well I've got some money I didn't I
don't know if it's necessarily allocated
for the townhouse so kind of my stats
are
um I've got 22 000 in emergency savings
um and I've got
um 3 200 on a Furniture bill that's a
zero percent that I'm paying 120 a month
on so pay that off today
it paid off today okay that's silly okay
so so now we got now we got 19 000 in
our emergency fund what other money you
got in savings you got money saved for a
down payment or not
I I don't have down payments the car
doesn't affect that you buy an eight
thousand dollar car you have eight
thousand dollars
okay what's wrong with that okay get
another eight
they're the cards are more expensive
these days no they're not you were
driving a 9 000 car get you an eight
thousand dollar car that car's market
value on that car was eight thousand
dollars that's why the insurance company
is giving you eight thousand dollars
that means you can go buy that car for
eight thousand dollars
well the sale on that car now when I
look for it is twelve to thirteen
thousand dollars no it's not mileage and
all that makes sense no it's not if it
is the insurance company needs to give
you twelve to thirteen thousand dollars
oh because your insurance policy says
that you have to get market value for
the car when it's total they don't get
to just make up a number and pay you
wholesale they pay you what it takes to
replace that car so if you can prove it
takes twelve thousand dollars to replace
that car you need to get twelve thousand
dollars from them because that's your
contract with them
but this idea that I need to move up in
car because I totaled my car is a bad
idea
use the money that you get and buy a car
that puts us out of the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with a work app on your smartphone it's
the only place to listen to the entire
back catalog of episodes download the
Ramsay Network app in your favorite app
store today
foreign
[Music]